hello everybody and welcome to part 11
of let's play from dust alright I got my
little woman woman yeah woman here who's
completely helpless trying to get to
that stone over there but I think I can
help her somehow now actually it's gonna
that problem come solve itself I don't
need to interfere
alright in case you forgot there's a bit
of a high tide business going on oh why
are you going that way there you go
smart and I need I'm it I imagine I need
the power engulf Oh infinite earth that
sounds interesting um maybe it's too
late now but I gotta wait until the next
tide goes down to get enough time to
send my people over so that they can
populate that one I think
and then hopefully with this knowledge
of the repel water doohickey they'll be
able to get there so that's the idea
they just see if I can feel a little
more land around it maybe to give him a
little helping hand Adam I don't know
I'm a noob at this game you've all seen
that bye bye now
right that village is safe she's got the
office she's going back there oh gosh
the problem is I gotta wait one more
turn help me or help me I'm so I'm so
afraid oh no oh I know what I can do
when they're done with that I can
jellify the water and make sure it
doesn't come here that'll work
oh I'm so smart oh shut up well you want
me to grab the ocean for you you're
welcome
oops sorry for the splash back it's
gonna go out on its own lady oh you so
bashful
all right almost there almost there come
on let's go
ocean all right almost there almost
there man
I'm just gonna send people there now
because oh damn it
cuz there's too much water of course of
course maybe I can move it no no come on
come on oh so ready for this
maybe needs a little more land come here
come here
that good now nope nope oh man now the
tides coming back into this this woman
doesn't even know what she's doing
wha I'm surrounded by idiots
alright let me try something else I
think I definitely need to get more land
around it to shape it out a bit more uh
alright I need I need sand I can't I
have sand there we go I must have like
one milliliter of water and yes I speak
in metric it's the system we should be
using ah sorry I didn't mean to get into
a system of measurement debate droppy
droppy I'll have we got the secret yet
did you die did you drown I think that
lady drowned oh my gosh can I get
someone from this village thank you
you're right there sir good job and now
go back to this village and not try to
cross an ocean to get back to here that
would be nice thank you
I guess I should feel more bad because I
guess you did kind of die but what
come on need more dirt dirt amplify
breath oh yeah
give me that soak up all the dirt sand
dirt ah I don't even know what to call
it anymore
okay is that good enough oh come on
there we go there we go oh go go peeps
go my peeps I'll go I'll go get the
water out of here
get out of here all that's coming back
up what what what was that what ah nope
that's right yeah out it oh you guys
better hurry you guys really really
better hurry you got 45 seconds alright
come on gasps ha believe in you actually
from what I've seen so far I've lost a
lot of faith in you guys but maybe you
can make it up now okay come on I'm
powerful but I can only hold back the
entire ocean for so long there we go now
give them the secret come on give them
the secret oh please give them the
secret they really need the secret okay
infinite earth oh well that's phenomenal
I would definitely like to make infinite
quantities of Earth let me try that
infinite oh yeah oh I like it I like it
fill this up so done flood oh look at
that oh yeah oh yeah I guess that
answers the question it's not sand it's
it's dirt earth that's cool
okay now they got the anti engulfing
thing oh please be okay I'll go see
there they go yeah
nice job guys I don't know how how
you're doing that but good job oh all
right do do do any more earth yeah what
if I happen to become pop oh yeah
oh I combined the breath cuz I'm so
smart amplify the infinite earth get out
of here
oh look at that oh yeah oh I kept right
cover this entire place with water
almost come come on now yeah kid on it
do do do do do do do do do is there's a
little puddle of water stopping here
don't worry I'll get the puddle it'll
stay safe in here oh there we are
oh why that person of all the people why
that person oh right just gotta wait for
it to go down a little more than I can
jellify it keep them protected infinite
amplified earth oh come on
infinite amplified Earth there we go
oh yeah look at that oh look at that let
me dam this up get out of here water
you're not welcome anymore oh yeah oh
that's really cool actually
but it may not be tall enough to stop it
whatever whatever oh you don't need help
you are helpless all right hurry Oh what
Oh jellified water too bad get out of
your ocean
all right trees propping up that's all
of them right yeah all four toes I want
to know what engulfed all does cuz that
sounds pretty darn cool Gulf Power
enables you to absorb and destroy matter
without having to release it oh I get it
oh I get it as cool okay
I could I could get into this so if I
just do it and then I start sucking up
water it just goes away cool for a long
time actually I could like drain an
entire ocean yeah out of here water up
gone off gone gone gone gone gone owner
of you can I don't know what the rules
about this game say about the ocean here
if it plays by the same water level
rules as you know just freestanding
water
I don't know toe nose slurping slurp
slurp Shirdi slurp alright jellify
water's gone I don't think I'm I don't
think I'm actually doing anything by
doing this I could see where this would
be useful but not right now not right
now
Wow let's do a little infinite earth
action
Devon missed I'm that fail wasted a
couple seconds
get out of here water Oh get out of here
Oh what I didn't amplify the breath darn
it
oh there goes my wall okay um go away I
keep forgetting about those messages
sorry about that I know that that's
probably annoying for some of you all
right looks like I finished my work here
I don't really see much else left to do
besides try to get 100% vegetation but
I'm not terribly worried about that I do
have to make sure that people can get
here without you know dying and oh okay
that's nice okay
and jellify water and make it make it
you guys oh sorry about that just just
keep banging your drums play in your
didgeridoos all right
see I got more I don't need it they're
almost there
they're gonna make it I believe in them
old man and you're quick for an old guy
look at you go and she's running and
you're still hobbling way faster good
job or he sorry sorry bro
Yorick you're a guy no you're a girl but
the other guy was a guy I can't tell
anymore
ah man y'all just gonna be bros guys
dudes people whatever bang it bang be
with you boom boom yeah
all right better go now before they you
know die
there we go on to the next one
okay
I'm guessing this actually is either a
shorter game or by the end of it it gets
unbelievably tough I'm guessing because
it hasn't been too hard right now but
one of the one commodore said that it
gets pretty aggravating later on but I
can deal well with aggravation bad as
I'm I need minutes after depo shot ma
uh-huh give Valley up oh you're on ganda
did that bullet G knock uh-huh okay
sounds good okay all right populate that
one but I also have to cut it here thank
you guys so much for watching I
appreciate it and I will see you in part
12 of let's play from dust bye bye